>> WE HAVE RECEIVED NO FORMAL OR
INFORMAL NOTIFICATION OF
ANYTHING.
KIM JONG UN HAD SENT PREVIOUSLY
THAT HE UNDERSTANDS THE NEED AND
AT THE OF THE UNITED STATES AND
THE REPUBLIC OF KOREA CONTINUING
IN ITS JOINT EXERCISES.
THEY ARE EXERCISES THAT ARE
LEGAL, PLANNED WELL, WELL IN
ADVANCE.
>> THEY ARE NEGOTIATING
OVERLEVERAGED AND, NOW OUR
DIPLOMATS ARE GETTING SOME
INSIGHT AS TO WHERE NORTH KOREA
IS REALLY HEADING.
>> I THINK NOT DOING MILITARY
EXERCISES WOULD BE A SHARE, SO
IN GOOD FAITH ON OUR PART, IT
DOESN'T CHANGE ANYTHING
PERMANENTLY BUT DELAYING THAT
UNTIL AFTER TALKS WOULD BE A
GOOD IDEA.
>> A REACTION FROM NORTH KOREA
TODAY THAT ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM.
SO MUCH OF A PROBLEM THAT THEY
MAY CANCEL THE UPCOMING SUMMIT,
JUNE 12TH, BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND KIM JONG UN.
THE NORTH KOREAN STATEMENT
SAYING THIS EXERCISE TARGETING
US, WHICH IS CARRIED OUT ACROSS
SOUTH KOREA AND TARGETING US IS
A FLAGRANT CHALLENGE TO THE
DECLARATION AND MILITARY
PROVOCATION, WHEN ENCOUNTERED TO
THE POSSIBLE TO ELEMENT ON THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
THE UNITED STATES WILL HAVE TO
UNDERTAKE CAREFUL DELIBERATIONS
ABOUT THE FATE OF THE PLANNED
NORTH KOREA AND U.S. SUMMIT IN
LIGHT OF THIS PROVOCATIVE
MILITARY RUCKUS JOINTLY
CONDUCTED WITH THE SOUTH KOREAN
AUTHORITIES.
SO, WHAT ABOUT THIS RUCKUS,
WHERE THIS LEADS AND WHAT IS IT?
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
JUDGE ANDREW NAPOLITANO, PHILIP
BUMP, AND STEVEN HILTON, FORMER
ADVISOR TO BRITISH
PRIME MINISTER DAVID CAMERON AND
HOST OF THE NEXT REVOLUTION HERE
ON FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
STEVE, IT SEEMS LIKE POSTURING.
IS THIS THING FALLING APART, DO
WE THINK?
>> I THINK IT'S PERFECTLY
POSSIBLE THIS IS PART OF THE
CHOREOGRAPHY.
WE NEVER, JUST AS WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING IS SEEN
HERE AS A BIG RISK, IT'S ALSO
LIKELY THAT BACK IN NORTH KOREA,
WHAT KIM IS DOING IS SEEN AS A
RISK AND HE MAY HAVE PEOPLE AND
FACTIONS THERE THAT HE NEEDS TO
PLACATE TO SHOW THAT HE'S NOT
CAVING IN.
AND THERE'S THIS DELICATE DANCE
THAT HAS TO BE DONE TO GET TO
THAT SUMMIT.
I THINK THE RESPONSE FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE CRUCIAL.
HE WANTS THIS REALLY BADLY, AND
I THINK HE'S GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING TO HERD THE CATS THE
RIGHT WAY TO GET IN THAT SUMMIT.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT
TO SEE HIS RESPONSE AND I THINK
THAT MATTERS MUCH MORE THAN
ANYTHING WE HEAR FROM OUR
DIPLOMATS.
>> Bret: IF YOU HEARD
RAND PAUL SAY, IS NOT SO BAD
THAT WE STOP THE MILITARY
EXERCISES.
THE PEOPLE AT THE PENTAGON'S
HEADS WOULD EXPLODE IT BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN DOING THAT FOR SO
TO THE REGION TO CONTINUE TO DO
IT.
>> IT CERTAINLY IS DOWN THE
LINE, I THINK EVERYONE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A SCENARIO WHERE
SETS OF EXERCISES ARE LESS
NECESSARY.
THE CRITICAL POINT IS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS GONE AGAINST
HIS ART OF THE DEAL MENTALITY
AND PUT HIS CARDS ON THE TABLE.
HIS CARDS ARE, I VERY MUCH WANT
THIS THING TO HAPPEN.
I THINK NORTH KOREA RECOGNIZE US
TO SOME THAT THAT GIVES HIM
LEVERAGE OVER THE UNITED STATES
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THIS
MOMENT TO TRY TO TWIST SOME ARMS
COME AND KNOWING PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAS SAID I HOPE TO WIN THE NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE, BUT HE HINTED HE
WOULD HELP THERE WOULD BE SOME
RECOGNITION FOR THIS.
IT'S ALSO INTERESTING TO NOTE,
NORTH KOREA IS ALSO A LITTLE
INCENSED IN THE WAY THAT THE
UNITED STATES HAS SORT OF
ASSUMED OWNERSHIP OVER THAT OF
ELEMENTS ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA, AND THIS COULD ALSO
BE TO SOME EXTENT AND A REACTION
OF THAT.
>> IT COULD BE SOME POSTURING,
TRYING TO SHOW STRENGTH COMING
UP TO THE SUMMIT, BUT WE HAVE
ALSO SEEN IN THE PAST, 1992,
20,002,007, BUT THEY HAD NICE
WORDS ABOUT MOVING TOWARD MORE
OF A PIECE, AND IT ENDED UP
BEING NOTHING TOWARD THE REGIME.
>> Bret: BASICALLY LOOKING AT
NORTH KOREA'S PAST, THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN GREAT ABOUT KEEPING UP WITH
THEIR PROMISES.
>> NOT AT ALL.
WHEN CONGRESS WOMAN MICK SALLY
AND US WERE HERE, I AGREE WITH
HER BUT I WONDER IF OUR
DIPLOMATS OUGHT TO HAVE KNOWN
THAT THIS WAS COMING?
I MEAN CERTAINLY, KIM KNEW THAT
THESE EXERCISES WERE GOING TO
TAKE PLACE.
RAND PAUL IS MY DEAR FRIEND BUT
YOU ARE RIGHT, THE MILITARY
HEADS WOULD EXPLODE.
IT'S TOO LATE      LATE TO STOPT
IT'S TOO LATE      LATE TO STOPI
IT'S TOO LATE      LATE TO STOPS
THING.
THE COST WOULD BE FAR TOO MUCH
AND THE IMPLICATION OF STOPPING
IT IS SO CONTRARY TO EVERYTHING
DONALD TRUMP STANDS FOR.
>> Bret: WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
STRENGTH.
>> CORRECT.
SO EITHER WE DIDN'T KNOW THIS
WAS COMING, OR WE POORLY
PREPARED AND THIS IS THE WAY WE
ARE.
AND AS STEVE SAID COMPANY HAS TO
APPEAL TO HIS BASE.
IT'S NOT A NATIONWIDE BASE, IT'S
A SMALL BASE, BUT TO ENSURE TO
SEE HOW HE STAYS IN TUB POWER.
>> Bret: THEN WE HAVE ZTE COME
THIS CHINESE COMPANY AND A WALK
BACK OF WHAT WERE GOING TO BE
SANCTIONS AGAINST THIS.
I SAW ON TWITTER AS SOMEONE
SPECULATE IN THAT MAYBE KIM
LOOKED AT THAT AND SAID, I WANT
A PIECE OF THAT.
MAYBE I SHOULD ASK FOR SOME TOO.
>> THAT'S ONE WAY OF LOOKING AT
IT.
I THINK THE SOPHISTICATION OF
THE DIFFERENT PLAYERS HERE IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN'T BE
CERTAIN ABOUT.
I THINK THE CHINESE DEFINITELY
FEEL, AS YOU ARE SAYING, BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT WANTS THIS SO
BADLY, THEY HAVE SOME LEVERAGE
HERE.
>> Bret: IN THAT CASE, THE
CHINESE DEAL WITH TRADE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT IF HE DOES ONE DEAL, THAT'S
ONE.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE INCREASED
SCRUTINY ACROSS THE SPECTRUM,
NOT JUST THIS BIG ONE BUT
THROUGHOUT THE TECHNOLOGY DEALS,
I THINK OVERALL THE STANCE
TOWARDS CHINA IS WAY TOUGHER
THAN IT WAS BEFORE AND I THINK
THAT NEEDS TO CONTINUE.
BUT TO GET THIS DELICATE PROCESS
ON AND KEEPING IT ON THE ROAD,
YOU MAY NEED TO GIVE THE ODD
CONCESSION HERE AND NOW.
>> THAT'S WHY POMPEO WAS OUT